laissez moi vous parler aujourd'hui
d'une catégorie de prix de smartphones
dont je vous parle assez peu c'est une
catégorie de smartphones aux alentours
des 100 euros on est vraiment dans
l'entrée de gamme et je vous en parle
peu l'entrée de gamme est là du coup il
mime à contacter la maison tient
monsieur gros si tu nous parler d'un
nouveau smartphone d'entrée de gamme
c'est celui là c'est le readme ses 11
j'ai dit ma coûté why not donc
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rémy pour
vous présenter ce tout nouveau
smartphone le readme ces ondes arlery mi
saison il est pas forcément fait pour
tout le monde
mais si vous voulez un smartphone aux
alentours des 100 euros
eh bien vous avez trouvé votre bonheur
enfin je vous dis 100 euros en fait il
coûte 119 euros
mais en ce moment vous avez une offre de
reprise de - 20 euros ce qui vous le
sort 99 euros et ça c'est cool et si
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description bono va garder
ça en tête sans 19 ans parce que c'est
le prix de vente du smartphone malgré
des promos de temps en temps et
compagnes et c'est ça mais c'est le prix
bad
donc on va dire que ce smartphone à 119
euros eh bien il fait pas mal de choses
mais il fait pas tout on va pas avoir le
maximum de performance a pas pouvoir
faire trouver forte mike dessus on ne
fera pas des photos et des ultra
grand-angle avec de la macro avec plein
de choses mais on peut faire des choses
pas mal et c'est justement ce qu'on va
regarder aujourd'hui regardez moi ça
comme c'est tout mignon retrouve
vraiment toutes les couleurs de remy à
chaque fois une sorte ce jeune là le nom
la référence du produit c'est tout et
comme ça on a accès à l'information en
direct c'est très facile je vous passe
de cotone boxing parce qu'à pâques grand
chose à dire par contre le smartphone
c'est celui là alors la première chose
qu'on doit que j'aime bien et bien c'est
on le voit la rade et le branding grill
me qui ressort on a cette bande sans
aucune strié là on a des dessins des
petits désinfection d'espèces dureront
qui vont s'écarter comme quand vous
jeter une pierre dans l'eau on est sur
un design géométrique plutôt pas mal qui
est inspiré d'un grand maître de la
peinture abstraite pourquoi pas voyez
vraiment une démarche artistique daria
c'est plutôt rigolo le design est sympa
avec le capteur photo qu'on va retrouver
ici bon ça c'est un grand classique pour
un sens c'est vraiment se retrouve un
peu partout des boutons pour le volume
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre en
dessous on a un haut parleur mono qui
situe la de la recherche en micro usb
micro une prise jack oui ça c'est bien
ici tiroirs de cartes sim avec double
aussi plus quatre micros et et ça c'est
très très cool sans dessus pas grand
chose et elle avant va retrouver un
grand écran de 6,5 pouces lcd qui
déverrouille grâce à de la connaissance
de visage mais sur le côté il m'a vu je
peut déverrouiller
j'ai une résolution hd + 6 6600 par 720
pixels avec un écran qui occupent 88 7%
de la face avant et un ratio vingt
neuvième vous le voyez ici on est une
caméra qui est planqué ici c'est un
grand standard et ça fonctionne et en
bande et une bordure noire qui assez
pour imminente mais une fois de plus
c'est normal à 119 euros
la prise en main est plutôt bonne on a
accès rapidement à l'écran soit
fonctionnerait n'diaye surprenante ce
côté là maintenant on va se dire à 119
euros quels sont les avantages et quel
est l'intérêt d'un site aux smartphones
alors ils sont à ses multiples déjà vous
avez un grand écran là on est dans les
standards qu'on trouve dans cette année
puis fin d'année dernière des grands
écrans de 6,5 pouces ça veut dire un
grand affichage pour afficher plein de
choses donc pour venir naviguer sur les
réseaux sociaux pour regarder des vidéos
du contenu multimédia
ça c'est bien côté performances voulait
diviser pas faire tourner forte naïve et
des jeux gourmands on va rester sur un
usage modéré sur deûle entrée de gamme
on a un et lioger 35
on a derrière de config soit 2 gigas de
ram soit 3 giga de ram
la techno drame c'est la lpddr2 4x et
dans les deux cas avec un stockage de 32
giga octet que vous pouvez monter grâce
à une carte microsd jusqu'à 256 gia on a
quelque chose de cohérent une fois de
plus par rapport à son prix dans
l'entrée de gamme
vous pouvez lire vos journaux pouvaient
regarder des films des séries joie des
petits jeux mais pas particulièrement
gourmands et des jeux pas gourmand sur
le playsport gagnant là mais surtout
dire est un des points forts de ce
smartphone et c'est vraiment ce qu'on
trouve dans le segment de l'entrée du
milieu de gamme
et bien c'est une très grosse batterie
de 5000 milliers en paire eur donc au
niveau de l'autonomie vous avez un
smartphone qui durera dans le temps et
ça c'est rassurant pour un contenu
multimédia faisait quand même ce grand
écran qui est très très très cool vous
avez un petit haut parleur mono sur le
côté dijonnais sont faits à ces médiums
et une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone à 119 euros
donc on va pas s'attendre à ce qu'il
nous fasse des merveilles et si vous
voulez aller plus loin et bien vous avez
une prise jack la wii pour brancher
votre casque filaire et si vous avez un
casque sans fil et bien vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 côte expérience logiciel
sert il me huet qui est basé sur un
android 10 fonctionnera bien la seule
chose venir vous recommander c'est
d'aller dans vos paramètres d'affichage
affichage et luminosité et vous venez
légèrement la température de couleurs de
l'écran pour venir casser un peu le côté
un peu bleuté bien réchauffé vous le
mettez pas réussi c'est ce qui irait
mieux
vous avez également un mode confort des
yeux mais qui par contre est vraiment
trop sur le marauder c'est pas
extraordinaire côté photo ou d'un double
capteur à l'arrière un premier de 13
mégapixels c'est la caméra principale
qui ouvre à f 2.2 avec un zoom numérique
x 4 et vous avez un capteur profondeur
de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre f 2.4 quand
est ce qu a d'abord vous avez caméra de
celle fille de 5 mégapixels vous pouvez
faire de la vidéo jusqu'en 1080p à 30
images par seconde ou alors en 720p et
si c'est pas un photophone je dirais que
c'est un smartphone qui fait des photos
qui vous permettra d'avoir quelques
souvenirs personnes ivres de la photo je
trouve que le rendu est assez honnêtes
pour voir qu'on est sur un smartphone a
à peine 100 euros à quelque chose près
on continue ici avec des petites gouttes
d'eau sur des feuilles ça fonctionnera
dans l'enfant qu'on voit effectivement
qui sillonnent une partie qui est un peu
plus floue ma noter que vous n'avez pas
de stabilisation optique et avec moi ça
ne pardonne pas photo avec le ciel et
bien voyez on va quand même bien les
nuages c'est pas cramé on a bien ici le
sapin on voit bien les branches devant
on continue ici avec un petit arbuste
c'est ok on vient où mais en x 2 ça
fonctionne x 4 c'est moins bien moins
précis mais une fois de plus c'est
normal et tout et son capteur principal
dont on vient vraiment zoomer dans
l'image caméra principale ça fait le taf
on se rapproche au père c'est pas très
très bon niveau de la gestion des
lumières x 4 non plus on oublie un petit
toréador dans un cendrier ok ça c'est
pas trop mal il faut pas se mettre trop
près pour faire des photos parce qu'il
est un petit peu de mal à faire le point
ça peut vraiment ce que fait le
reprocher le rendu au niveau de la
caméra telle fille est aussi vraiment en
est là c'est pareil c'est un peu trop
près il a eu un peu de mal à faire le
point sur la fleur a contrario lorsque
je me recule et bien rendus et pas trop
trop mal
ça reste vraiment cohérent et puis une
fois de plus sur notre smartphone à 100
euros ça fait le taff exactement la même
chose ici c'est correct
quant au mode portrait et bien le rendu
est assez honnête on n'a pas beaucoup de
performances à pour revenir vraiment
tout calculer mais malgré tout il vient
pas trop mal mais des tours ici on voit
quelques petits cheveux qui ont été un
peu coupé mais c'est pas anormal est ici
entre les doigts
eh bien il s'en sort pas plus mal qu'un
smartphone qui coûterait un peu plus
cher dans ce que dans l'ensemble le
rendu est assez qualitatif qui dit
smartphone d'entrée de gamme des
smartphones qui n'a pas de certification
parce qu'une certification ça coûte de
l'argent et ça viendrait augmenter le
prix donc bon y'a pas
particulièrement d'intérêt à venir faire
certifier ce smartphone on est sur un
produit une fois de plus je voulais dit
à 119 euros
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description qu'est
ce qu'il faut retenir de ce raid mis ses
onze c'est que ça vous paraîtra d'avoir
l'essentiel sur android pour faire
tourner des jeux pas trop gourmands vous
visionnez du multimédia des séries pour
aller naviguer sur vos réseaux sociaux
pour relever des emails pour communiquer
avec ses amis et pour faire quelques
photos souvenirs avec votre caméra
principale on va venir utiliser les
fonctions essentielles de smartphones
dans un produit qui est honnête et que
je trouve plutôt bien réussi à vous de
me dire maintenant ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner s'est pas déjà fait puis
quand son petit bouton vous avez
quelques papas ici parce qu'on va parler
de teck a plein de choses qui arrivent
il ya une très grosse actu sur ce je
vous embrasse
j'en vois beaucoup d'amour et il ya très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]
au moins
à vélo
m
chicago
je trouve